so our first can I say oh moment is
that we were just getting our feet wet
in the world of facebook marketing and
and we have this genius plan where where
we realized on facebook we could pay a
certain amount to acquire a fan we found
the price we could say then has its
revelation that you know I can make
a Styrofoam kuzey for half that price
and shipping rates on just that kind of
problems are much much less kind of
added together than the price of
acquiring one single fan base book
instead of running ads on Facebook we
would run an organic campaigns that was
share our page and if our page hit
50,000 fans on Facebook we're going to
send out koozies everyone who signed up
and share our page so we did it we ran
the campaign we ended up getting to
75,000 fans and we had to ship out
30,000 kooky what we thought great you
know to ship them out and and we'll be
done but the process of shipping 30,000
2 z's is no sympathy we packed accuse
you an envelope took it to the post
office and said please ship this to you
know XYZ address with one single stamp
on it they rejected that we have to pay
five times the price we're assuming
we're going to pay so we can start
looking into the most advanced vacuum
sealing technologies we started drown it
duct tape down all the envelopes we
started trying to use like slices you
push them down and somehow gets into old
nothing work then we hire
contract workers just to come in and
pack koozies and envelope for probably
about three weeks straight that was our
big associate moment it was in the in
the states are kind of you know
successful campaign that was a huge
realization of wow 30,000 a humongous
number and you really need to do more
research on the way
[Music]